[Music]
you know i'm not just the host of conan
i'm also the spiritual leader for over 3
000 conan staff members it's come to my
attention that someone on staff who's
very close to me
uh had something valuable go missing
possibly even stolen
it's my job to solve this mystery as
quickly as possible let's go
it's chicken
[Laughter]
you're my assistant are you not yes i am
how long have you worked for me
a little over four and a half years okay
quick question did you send this email
out to the entire staff
i know this is a complete abuse of hey
everybody but if you stole my gigolo's
mug i'm going to find you
and destroy you did you send that
uh yes i did a lot to talk about first
of all what's a gigolo's mug
uh giggles is a show on showtime that
follows
gigolos in
las vegas real gigolos yes real gigolos
and then my friend megan gave me the mug
as a gift and it says gigolo's on one
side and on the other it says working
stiff
it's looking stiff like a joke
yes
i think so what's the joke i think it's
just like
like a
like it's a stiff
like working stick
like a penis is different all right
uh you like the occasional drink yes
that is completely completely is it
possible you had a little drinky winky
and maybe misplaced it i had a drinky
like this morning i had a drinky winky
no like yesterday late in the day maybe
do you ever drink at work
let's just leave it alone what's this
can you drink out of this that's fine i
do drink out of that what is that a cool
logo of something it's an astronaut with
a boombox okay
you're in charge of my life right yes i
am actually
lindsay are you aware that
sona's gigolo's mug is missing yes who
do you have any theories about what
happened to the monk people just take
[ __ ] all the time what do you mean
people steal stuff you've had stuff
stolen yeah what's been stolen of yours
well
tell me i'm concerned i'm not just the
host of the show i'm also
i made a mark to prove if someone was
stealing my booze and then someone stole
it what kind of office is this
why is this at work
[Applause]
down time
down time you have downtime when you
take a bot this is what detectives in
the 20s did
uh sona's missing a mug
that promotes a show with male
pornography
i want to find it because i'm not just
the host i'm also sort of the spiritual
leader for our staff of
4 000 how many people do we have on
staff it's 185 i think
are you okay i think i think with crew i
mean
i don't know exactly i think that's true
when people ask for i thought i was in
the thousands but
that was an answer we can go with that
though
no you just
okay
i use anything missing of yours has
anything going on what not in a long
time but um a few years ago someone
stole my really nice headphones right
off my desk uh i'll pay for it how much
do they work no seriously how much were
they worth give just give me yeah just
give me a ballpark figure and i'll pay
for it how much like five hundred
dollars that's way too much i didn't
think it's gonna be like it would be
like forty dollars yeah that's when you
guys go for these things no i don't have
that kind of money
can you tell us your name my name is
john please yes
excuse me kramer
how dare you i'm trying to conduct an
investigation here hang up the hang on
[Applause]
i see you have some fried chicken of
course is that kentucky fried chicken it
is i think it's the best chicken there
is
some money now lindsay says that alcohol
was taken from her death do you keep
alcohol on your desk no i should though
probably no why should you
make the day more fun
okay
could you take her alcohol in oh because
i'm irish
no i didn't take her alcohol i i'm not a
big drinker
how's the chicken by the way that's
pretty good i love kentucky fried
chicken
finest chicken made no one doesn't like
the corn
colonel's dead
what the hell was that i'm trying to get
money wait colonel's dead what's your pr
what is wrong with everybody on the
staff
[Applause]
did you take it i did not you're a liar
i'm not a liar you took the mug did not
take the money took the mug why would i
take the mug why did you take them up
did not do it okay tell me you did it
and i won't fire you didn't do it okay
all right so you're gonna stick to your
story i'm gonna stick to my story you
did it you took it it did not work what
did you want to jiggle this mug for free
perfect
did you stuff it down your pants would
you say to me i'm insane what kind of
place is this i'm the spiritual leader
of over ten thousand staff members here
on time man that explains a lot about
this place okay this is big we just got
a crack in the case uh we believe that
staff member named rj
rj may have the mug
where does rj work where what building
is that building 44.
this is the most i've walked in los
angeles in three years
stay calm everyone it's gonna be fine
rj how's it going good to see you good
to see you we are looking for a mug a
gigolo's mug
yeah
i think it's right here
why do you have this mug
an intern brought it over
this is incredible so you're clearly
innocent this isn't your fault an intern
brought it to you correct
and now it's my job
to see that an unpaid intern is fired
rj thank you let's hug it out let's get
in here let's just hold each other for a
while
[Music]
my eyes are closed
ah come on that's nice rj he said an
intern brought it over
how would an intern why would an intern
take a mug off your desk it's in the
cabinet in the kitchen
wait you left this in the cabinet in the
kitchen and then you're wondering why it
was missing
yeah you made it sound like it was
stolen off your desk no no
no thank you for finding me oh thank you
that took what how many how long did
that take i returned the mug i spent an
hour of my day finding it and it took
how long to get a thank you
put a timer on that and just show it at
the bottom right now yeah that's how
long it took
little frankies go a long way
you're welcome would be better than what
you just did
that's why i don't say thank you to you
ever it's because that's what you do
do you see
i don't say thank you because then
you're like oh sona said thank you what
an exciting moment in life this is
absolutely incredible incredible yeah
taking this i actually work on the show
we have a staff of alcoholics
and screw-ups